It appears that Marvel and DC fans have slightly
different preferences when it comes to how
they get their respective fixes.
A new survey conducted by streaming and cord-cutting
news site Flixed examining the attitudes of
Americans toward streaming vs. movie theater
viewing revealed that Marvel Cinematic Universe
aficionados are more likely than DC die-hards
to catch the latest installment in the theater.
The difference was relatively slight, but
with millions upon millions of dollars at
play each time a superhero tentpole picture
hits screens, it still feels pretty significant.
"You're not the only one cursed with knowledge."
"My only curse it you!"
Survey respondents were asked if they would
consider catching the next installment of
four popular franchises at home rather than
in the theater, with those uninterested in
any given franchise being excluded from the
results.
When it came to Mighty Marvel vs. the Distinguished
Competition, 34 percent insisted that they
would rather see the next MCU flick in the
theater, as compared to 27 percent for the
DC movie universe.
Again, those seven percentage points make
a pretty big difference when you're talking
about millions of moviegoers, and those numbers
are suggestive of a couple different things.
First, it's pretty obvious that Marvel Studios
has utterly captured the hearts of fans, considering
that a plurality of moviegoers of all ages
would be willing to pay a premium to watch
first-run films in the comfort of their homes.
The fact that the next MCU movie, whatever
it might be, would entice fully a third of
those who want to see it to head out to the
theater even if they had the option to watch
at home is pretty impressive.
Second, the DC cinematic universe may have
suffered a bit from the comparatively poor
quality of its early offerings, but that doesn't
mean that fans still aren't on board with
what Warner Bros. and DC Films are cooking
up next.
With over a quarter of them preferring the
theater experience over watching at home for
the next installment, it's clear that there's
still a great deal of goodwill toward the
franchise; recent hits such as Aquaman, Shazam!,
and Joker have probably helped quite a bit
in this regard.
As for the other two franchises, 34% of interested
moviegoers the same number scored by the MCU
asserted that the next entry in the Disney-owned
Star Wars franchise would be a must-watch
in the theater.
The final franchise in question: Warner Bros.-owned
Harry Potter, which could draw 25% of its
fans back to the theater with another installment.
These were just a few of the interesting tidbits
of information yielded by the study, which
took a broad view of the opinions of a wide
cross-section of Americans regarding the convenience
of streaming vs. the experience of theater
viewing.
Respondents were lumped into the categories
of "Millennial," "Gen X," and "Baby Boomer"
and if you think you've got each age range
pegged, you're likely to be shocked at some
of the results.
For example, when it came to the simple question
of whether respondents would prefer to see
new movies in general at home or in theaters,
you might think that Millennials would be
all about the streaming as compared to the
other age groups but if you did think that,
you would apparently be wrong.
By far, Gen X respondents came down most heavily
on the side of home viewing, with a whopping
73% saying that they would prefer to stream
new releases.
As for the responses of Millennials and Boomers
to the question, they were not that different.
61% of the former preferred home viewing as
compared to 63% of the latter, and factoring
in neutral responses, the percentage of respondents
from each age group that straight-up preferred
theater viewing was the same 31%.
Regardless of age group, the survey's responses
indicated that the forthcoming, so-called
"streaming wars" are no joke.
Fully two-thirds of respondents also asserted
that as streaming services proliferate in
earnest over the next three years, they will
definitely see fewer movies in theaters even
though slightly over half of those responding
agreed that movies produced for in-theater
viewing (as opposed to streaming originals)
were generally more entertaining.
As to the franchise-specific question, though,
one could argue that Disney and Warner Bros.
should take very different things away from
the responses.
Disney would be well-served to keep doing
what it's been doing, particularly as that
pertains to the MCU; Warner Bros., on the
other hand, could stand to double down on
its recalibration efforts of the last couple
years.
One final note: it should be very interesting
to see, with Marvel Studios planning to extend
the MCU's tendrils to the small screen via
soon-to-debut streamer Disney+, whether fans
will be just as psyched to catch the next
chapter in theaters in, say, two or three
years.
Marvel has consistently gotten butts in theater
seats for over a decade, and the studio scored
the highest-grossing film of all time in Avengers:
Endgame ... but the times are a-changin'.
"I see this as an absolute win."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.